guys have both played
uh badass hackers and i'm just curious
what is the secret to playing a hacker
on screen
typing really convincingly um
i don't know like i think that it's
getting a lot of exposition down
you know a lot of tech jargon like
getting that in and being able to
deliver it like convincing me it's
challenging
um
but yeah
i don't know
i think you just have to bring your own
style and it and it'll it'll be okay
yeah i mean i i feel like i i didn't
have that much time to learn how to use
the things properly but i hope i kind of
did it in a right way or in an authentic
way so you believe what i'm doing there
in that moment
but um
i mean yeah knowing what you're doing in
some some sort of way so for me it was
really helpful to have someone come over
that is in this tech business and can
show me all these different ways and
secrets and little things just to have
an idea of
what this world is so that was fun
i think maybe i guess from from my
perspective it's like just looking like
you believe what you're doing
yeah
key um there's a great bike stunt
sequence in this movie with the stairway
and i'm just curious were you guys
excited to not be doing that stunt or
did you want to be doing that stunt no
i'm i'm excited to not do that i have
terrible spatial awareness i would have
gone immediately into the first table or
person
um i have that problem where you know
like
when you what's it called like fixed
target where like you see something and
you just go towards it instead of like
around it when i'm on a bike i'm not
good at it oh god
yeah it's not safe
it has to be flat no people around and
no obstacles
it's a really cool sequence though in
the movie i was very i mean that whoever
did that stunt
major props
yeah he absolutely smashed it yeah
so good
100 um i love learning about the making
of movies what's like a what's something
you think might surprise people to learn
about the making of this film i think um
it's surprising that a lot of
uh like we shot in prague in in the
czech republic and actually a lot of
that kind of landscape and uh like a lot
of the places that we were in were
really kind of in and around prague and
like that's why it's such a great city
and such a popular filming location
um
but yeah i mean just the fact that we
shot this during covid um and we managed
to complete
it without any any kind of major
incidents uh is
like a miracle
because at the time the czech republic
sadly was one that had one of the
highest um
kind of infection and death rates at the
time so
we we somehow did the impossible what
felt like the impossible anyway i think
like all the car scenes and stuff or a
lot of them weren't like real driving
and so we we shot with these um screen
what are they called natalie they're
like led screens like their leds
yeah yeah which was which was really
interesting uh also for myself because i
haven't shot with that yet and with
green screen and just with green screen
so
that was like a fun and interesting
thing to learn
um at what point in the shoot were you
guys both like ready to just rip that
van apart and say i'm out of here or or
was it actually great to be shooting in
the van all the time
you know we were in the van for so long
in the group that there were moments
where we just couldn't stop giggling and
laughing and we couldn't concentrate so
we really had to like open the doors i
think we didn't have enough oxygen in
there and just go out and have a rest
for 10 minutes yeah it got a bit giddy
on a couple of occasions for sure just
because we were in
inside a sound stage inside a van
and in a really small quarters and it
got a bit yeah it got a bit like we just
got a bit giddy in a bit like okay
everyone just take a minute get some
fresh air
and regroup because yeah it's a lot of
talking a lot of fast maneuvering around
each other and
you know after however many hours of
doing that it all just got a bit like
we've got a bit blurry and a bit like
okay we need to step out but it was fun
though i like a good like laugh on set
when
it just think it makes it fun
i am curious um if you guys actually are
there certain movies or certain things
you do prior to like making a movie like
this um did you watch certain heist
films did i mean like how do you get
sort of get ready yeah missus definitely
gave us a list of movies that he felt
inspired by and
um
and yeah that so i watched a couple of
days and watched a couple that i liked
when i was um growing up and
um
but for me it was definitely like as the
kind of action
heist element of it uh i
i
knew that we would have like amazing
people then
i guess consultants on all of that
um but for me it was really about kind
of
delving into character about who gwen
was and what her story is and where she
came from and why she does things that
she does and that for me is like the
real work um for for me personally and
in coming stepping into the first scene
and knowing
and knowing where she's been um
immediately and so that was like just
the kind of fun stuff for me and then
obviously doing the stunts because you
have to do a lot of a lot of
training um i think i really liked this
regrouping of us and rehearsing three
weeks um prior to shooting the movie so
we really got to like get together and
like
um
yeah um bond the whole group and so we
did like boxing together and like like
weird like stunt kind of things and
um like group
um how to like react in a group when
you're like um going into a room and
stuff and how do you like take care of
the other person that's with you and so
that was really fun like to like bond in
this kind of way
yeah the kind of like tactical training
we did like if you know what you would
learn in the military or something if
you were a group
kind of you know scanning a building or
a room and what you would do and so that
was great team building i think
on that note i got to stop i'm just
going to say thank you so much for your
time i hope the film's a huge hit thank
you thank you thank you for your time
you